es gehört der geduldsfaden es gerade
gerissen
hallo mein name ist khan herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video werde ich bin back in meiner alten
kulisse zurück aus dem urlaub ja cool
hier aber wir kommen zurück zum video
thema ihr seht ihr schon im titel
eingeblendet es ist wirklich etwas auf
das ich sehr sehr sehr lange gewartet
habe sehr viele leute die ich bisher
meiner youtube laufbahn kennengelernt
getroffen habe haben mir gesagt dass das
ganze nie klappen wird allerdings
bedanke ich mich bei euch und allen
anderen dass es jetzt endlich geklappt
hat uns zwar spreche ich heute mit
beauty bei ich habe ein gespräch mit dem
größten youtuber der welt und nein das
ist jetzt nicht irgendwie das ich mit
dem body board mit der website rede
sondern okay doch ich bin ein opfer ich
hätte ja wahrscheinlich alle noch den
clever bot bei dem es ist halt so dass
man ihnen irgendwelche sachen senden
kann und mit ihm chatten kann und er
antwortet halt in echtzeit auf die
gestellten fragen bzw die sache über die
man hat redet und das gibt es jetzt in
der weihnachtszeit hier auch mit polizei
und zwar sieht er hier schon aus wie
eine mischung aus einem weihnachtsmann
und als allererstes schreibe ich mir
einfach mal guten morgen mit einem
smiley und dann schauen was er darauf
antwortet und war antwortet juli bei
darauf wie geht's
er ist auf jeden fall schon mal ein
netter als der clever bot ich bin ein
wenig erkältet schreibe ich ihnen mal
ein wenig ja ein wenig so das habe ich
ja gerade schon gesagt die ab juli bot
was heißt hier ein wenig alter aber es
ist mega krass wie er wirklich
das ist ein
mega krass wie der plot hier direkt auf
die fragen eingeht dass tante auf jeden
fall viel besser als übrigens könnt ihr
bald auch wieder die pop sockets hier
bestellen und zwar nicht nur dieser
farbe sondern auch in schwarz aber dazu
demnächst mehr also checkt auf jeden
fall den luca shop aussiehst du
eigentlich center oder beauty teichmann
der beauty bot sieht hier aus wie so
eine mischung aus der ich bin ein
mädchen ho und du
[Musik]
du bist ein mädchen beauty bot das kann
doch irgendwie nicht sein nein ich bin
ein junger okay ich bin ein mädchen hoch
dann frage ich ihn du bist ein mädchen
fragezeichen nein ich bin ein junge das
was willst du dich ja ok comcom schreibe
ich mir einfach da das jetzt aus der
welt ist bist du ein werwolf
na gut ich verstehe es nicht er sagt wir
zuerst dass er ein mädchen das dann
frage ich nach das ist ein junger und
dann sage ich einfach okay dann sagt er
okay da das jetzt aus der welt ist du
bist ein werwolf warum ich bin kein
werwolf lieber beauty bord nein du bist
ein roboter die welt nicht mehr ab juni
bot was bin ich was bin ich lieber
beauty wort beantworte es mir los ein
roboter ich bin robert ein werwolf unten
roboter was sagt ihr denn dann und was
sind dann meine zuschauer fragezeichen
das würde ich dann auch mal
interessieren okay dann bis morgen
okay leute das war's
ihr wollt könnt ihr einen kanal
abonnieren es kostenlos und den zurück
zum thema punkt punkt punkt wer bist du
wirklich und jetzt ich bin 16 jahre alt
ok sonnenbad mit 16 jahren so haben es
auf jeden fall krass also bist du 16 ein
mädchen ein junge und ein werwolf
gleichzeitig lieber clever bot clever
bot
verwechsle ich schon bei wird im clever
wollen ein nein du hast doch selbst
gesagt über bio die bordell cody
verstieß ich und du hast gesagt dass du
eine roboter bis nein habe ich nie das
hast du mir gesagt vorhin hast du es
gesagt
wenigstens war die antwort korrekt habe
nie gesagt dass ich ein roboter bin
punkt punkt punkt habe ich auch nicht
behauptet du hast da steht vorhin hast
du es gesagt ich habe dann gesagt ich
habe nie gesagt dass ihren roboter bin
und dann er habe ich auch nicht
behauptet du hast es doch je gesagt mal
willst du mich verarschen lieber beauty
potters kann doch alles nicht wahr sein
nein hatte ich eigentlich nicht vor
sorry wenigstens entschuldigt er sich
entschuldigung angenommen soll scheint
es mal wieder fröhlichen das gespräch
mit einem smiley danke okay wir sind
wieder richtige braus jetzt fährst du
heute silvester lieber pur bot das würd
mich interessieren weiß ich noch nicht
und du vor allem so und du bist du zwei
ausrufezeichen und ein fragezeichen die
ich werde auf jeden fall knallen so den
einen oder anderen bürger meine damen
und herren
und jetzt ich glaub du hast das mit dem
sarkasmus noch nicht drauf
[Musik]
ich war heute silvester möchtest du
mitkommen also wir laden im juni bot
jetzt einfach mal ein nein ich dachte du
bist ein werwolf lieber bruder bord also
du bist ein junger ich war doch wohin
auch verstehe die welt nicht mehr was
bin ich denn jetzt was bin ich denn hier
hits live view die bord antworte es mir
einfach weiß ich nicht sagst du es mir
das ist grammatikalisch auf jeden fall
komplett falsch also mal eine kurze
zusammenfassung von unserem bisherigen
gespräch ich hab ihn gefragt wie er ist
und er meint er ist ein junge ein
mädchen werwolf gleichzeitig und dann
hat er mehrmals behauptet dass ich ein
roboter boj board junge alles mögliche
bin und jetzt widerlegt er das alles
irgendwie wieder und ich sollte selber
sagen also sage ich jetzt einfach mal
ich bin 20 jahre alt und ein junge die
beauty bord so ich auch wann hast du
geburtstag
also ist er auch 20 jahre alt und ein
junge am 21 februar lieber bot willst du
meinen geburtstag auch wissen ja gerne
was willst du mit mir machen
ich verstehe gerade nicht worauf
hinaus will ich will mit dir deinen
geburtstag feiern lieber keyboard really
cool ich auch mit dir jetzt vermischte
auch noch englisch mit deutschen kulig
auch mit dir schreibe ich einfach mal
genauso zurück und er antwortet und dann
warum setze dir jetzt eine sonnenbrille
auf und warum bist du viel ist was soll
dann passieren lieber beauty bord was
soll was wie was soll was du hast wie a
ständig steht sagt urs mir lieber privat
was soll was was soll ich dir sagen was
das soll fragezeichen und er antwortet
atmen wir sollen alle atmen so eine
erkenntnis
juli bot offizielle statement ihren dich
mega korrekt danke das uns diesen tipp
gegeben hast du auch lieber beauty
butter sind auch die antwort kam schnell
wie oft bist du in der woche das würde
ich mal wirklich interessieren gar nicht
[Musik]
ihr habt es gerade selber gesehen ich
frage diesen pizza ob er atmet er sagt
ja ich frage wie oft muss und der woche
gar nicht okay es ist bei mir
mittlerweile der der punkt gekommen wo
mein geduldsfaden bis aufs äußere
äußerste angespannt ist
es gehört sondern geduldsfaden ist
gerade gerissen
was willst du eigentlich von mir er
verarscht mich hier die ganze zeit im
bottich sollte was fragen
der brauch ist was solltest du frage
lieber bot etwas über den comedian
harmon ist wissen was lieber keyboard
wer ist das dass du so gemein das gerade
wirklich dein ernst beauty bot ja das
ist mein ernst ok warum bin ich gemein
sagt es mir doch bitte weil du mich
nicht willst wie sowieso will ich die
nicht wieso will ich dich nicht lieber
keyboard und er antwortet überlegt noch
warum nicht
warum denn willst du mich heiraten
das was ihr vom video meine damen und
herren
gefallen wenn es das getan hat las auf
jeden fall mal ein leichter und weil 800
passiert gar nichts
wenn ihr gerade noch dran sein und euch
dieses chaotische video bis zum ende
gegeben hat dann schreibt mal pipi und
in die kommentare wenn ihr wollt dass
ich das nächste mal das vielleicht
normal mache noch mal mit dem portrait
de und in noch ein paar fragen stellen
wie findet ihr in smiley eingeblendet
wenn ihr da draufsteht könnte meinen
kanal abonnieren es ist free kostenlos
ich verpasst keine videos mehr und ich
würde mich sehr darüber freuen
yay und hier findet irgendwie anderes
video eingeblendet ist locker auch
komplett beschissen
solltet ihr auf jeden fall beim
abschicken weil vielleicht ist ja doch
ganz cool
ja